a hundred years ago Henry Ford and
Thomas Edison were friends they were
rivals but they were friends and they
made a bet as to how the cars of the
future would evolve Edison thought it
would be the electric car and he
pioneered many inventions and batteries
for is said nah no way I mean it's going
to be it's going to be fossil fuels is
gonna be gasoline well everybody knows
who won but the real question is who
will win in the future will Thomas
Edison have his revenge and the answer
is very simple it comes from physics if
you take gasoline realize that in some
sense you're looking at concentrated
sunlight concentrated sunlight since the
time of the dinosaurs it is packed with
energy per kilogram the number of joules
of energy inside gasoline is much larger
than the energy content of a battery so
it takes a very large cumbersome battery
to compensate for the energy contained
in gasoline which is really quite
efficient it's been refined over decades
pollutes like hell but it is very
efficient that's why we need a new
generation of batteries some people
think that nano batteries may be the
future it turns out that if you want to
store energy you can store energy in
parallel plates these are called
capacitors plus minus plus minus plus
minus plates plates can be made
extremely thin as soon as molecules
meaning that in principle you can sort
an enormous amount of energy using
carbon nano fibers and plates called
graphene some people think that
nanotechnology may give us super
batteries but not yet nanotechnology is
still in its infancy so we just have to
get used to the fact that gasoline is
still very efficient